We've already seen a few commands
that work with file names.
For example, ls lists the files
in the current directory.
Right now we have just one file,
things.zip.
Let's go ahead and unzip that so
we have more files to work with.
If you didn't download thing.zip earlier
refer to the instructors note below for
instructions.
The unzip command typically
takes one argument.
The file name of the file to unzip.
As it works, unzip lists the files and
directories it's uncompressing.
Let's use ls to see all these new files.
It looks like we have some text
files and some directories too.
Another useful command is cat,
give cat a list of file names and
it'll print out
the contents of the files.
For example,
we can read bivalves.txt and
gastropods.txt by running this command.
Cat is a funny name for a command.
But it makes sense when you realize
it's an abbreviation for concatenate.
Cat, concatenate files,
and outputs the result.
You can also use cat
to read a single file.
Just give it one file name.
A lot of people use cat as their go
to command for reading short files.
Later on in the course,
we'll learn other ways of reading files
that work well with larger files.
If you were watching closely you may
have noticed that I was able to type
those commands with super human speed.
I'm not actually a very
good typist though,
I was just using one of the shells built
in time saving features, tab completion.
If you press the tab key
while typing a word,
the shell will try to
autocomplete it for you.
For example, I can cat bivalves.txt
by tapping cat bi and pressing tab.
Since bivalves.txt is the only
file that starts with bi,
the shell can autocomplete it for me.
But what happens if you use tab
completion when there's more than
one match?
Let's try it.
Two files start with gas,
gastropods.txt and gastropodsdraft.txt.
When I hit the tab key, the shell
auto completes as far as it can.
If I hit tab again, the shell will
tell me all the files that match.
Since I want to read
gastropods_drafts.txt I
can type an underscore and press tab
again to enter the complete file name.
All right, we've read files
from the command line, but
we can do more than that.
There are also commands for
analyzing files.
WC is the word count program.
It tells us how many lines,
words, and bytes are in a file.
Since bivalves.txt has
one species per line and
two lines of citations, we know that the
file describes ten different critters.
Another command for
analyzing files is diff.
Diff compares files and
shows you how they differ.
This can be useful if you
have multiple versions or
editions of the same file and you want
to know what changes have been made.
In this case, it looks like
a left file gastropods.txt has
one line that the right file
gatropods_draft doesn't have.
This little angle bracket points in
the direction of the file that includes
that change